[Narrator] The histogram filter's biggest disadvantage is it scales exponentially,
and the reason is any grid that is defined over k dimensions
will end up having exponentially many grid cells in the number of dimensions,
which is really unfortunate because
we can't really represent high dimensional grids really well.
So, it works really well for low dimensional problems
like 3 dimensional robot localization problems.
The kalman filter in contrast, under certain assumptions,
is quadratic.
All we represented was a vector, the mean, and the covariance matrix,
and the covariance matrix is quadratic.
And it turns out all the computation, if your measurements space is a fixed size,
ends up to be quadratic without a proof here.
So, you just have to take it by faith,
but the queer thing is this is a much more efficient method.
So, if you have a 15, 20 dimensional state space,
the kalman filters will be more efficient than the histogram filters.